you're watching the daily climate show
here on sky news coming up on today's
programme
a storm barra hits the uk and ireland
why we can expect more frequent extreme
weather of all kinds in future
as mp's grill alex sharma on the results
of cop 26 how can countries be held to a
count on their climate target
and changing animal diets could feeding
cattle seaweed reduce methane emissions
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up for the
solutions
tens of thousands of homes are now
without power in ireland falling trees
and flooding and more disruption is
expected across the uk overnight a storm
borough brings guelph-4's winds in from
the atlantic the latest named storm only
comes days after 10 days after storm
irwin which left chaos across scotland
and northern england where some people
have only today had their electricity
reconnected
or storms at this time of the year are
common of course but climate change will
bring more frequent examples of extreme
weather of all kinds we'll be hearing
shortly from a leading climate scientist
on how we can make the connection but
first ender braided reports from south
wales
will you join us here in port cole where
storm barra has been battering the
coastline of south wales for hours now
wind speeds of up to 62 miles per hour
recorded here this evening the worst of
the storm is yet to come it actually hit
almost gale force 11 out at sea in the
past couple of hours hasn't been as bad
as people were expecting but as i say
the worst of barra is to come in the
next few hours now
unbelievably some people actually went
out windsurfing in the storm here in
port call earlier on you can see those
pictures now and they obviously knew
what they were doing they went out to
see and they got back in safely but
incredible to witness that earlier on
here in port cole as i say the worst of
storm barra is on its way and
more and more you know we're seeing
these storms last week it was stone
irwin this week's storm barrow coming so
quickly after such a disruptive storm
last week really testing people's
resilience but there has been no major
loss of power in wales today
no damage to property and thankfully no
injuries anywhere so
storm barris still blasting the
coastline of south wales and climate
scientists reckon that in years to come
we are going to see more examples of
extreme weather storm after storm and
they say that it's all because of
climate change but here in wales the
town of port carl bracing itself for a
very very stormy night
under brady there well joining me now is
dr frederick otto who's climate
scientist and co-founder of the world
weather attribution project thanks for
joining us this evening now the weather
can't be attributed to climate change
alone can it
no every weather event has always
multiple causes and there's always a
role to play of the chaotic variability
of
natural weather but climate change can
make
extreme weather events more intense and
more frequent
so how does it work how does the science
of attribution work
so the signs of attribution is answering
the question whether for a particular
type of extreme event say a storm uh
like like barra
the climate change has made the event
more likely and more frequent and so a
storm is is
consists of several aspects so one is
the wind and we don't actually see
a big change in the winds intensity and
the frequency of heavy wind itself but
the other aspect of such storms that
often leads to massive damages is
heavy rainfall
and we do see a strong increase in heavy
rainfall
from storms like associated with storms
like borough from climate change and how
we find now whether climate change plays
a role is that we look at
possible weather
in today's climate using
weather forecast models and compare it
with possible weather in a world without
the co2 emissions from burning fossil
fuels now what's interesting is that the
situation in madagascar has been
described by the wfp which is the world
food programme as a climate change
induced famine but you disagree with
that
it is important to realize that not all
extreme events are made more likely and
more intense because of climate change
so
all heat waves are
many heavy rainfall events are droughts
in several parts of the world but not in
all and what makes
um
an event an extreme event a catastrophe
is always hugely dependent on exposure
and vulnerability so who and what is in
harm's way were there warnings and and
so on and in madagascar and southern
madagascar it's an area that has
very large natural variability so
there are always years which have good
rainy seasons and years with bad rainy
seasons but the population is so poor
and so dependent on good rainy seasons
that even without climate change a bad
rainy season leads to huge food
insecurity and it's important
to not blame everything on climate
change because that totally takes the
agency away from local decision-making
and from
we can build resilience and we can
adapt to today's climate but in and also
we can adapt to some changes in future
climate that we absolutely see and also
in madagascar just not for these type of
droughts but for heat events dr
frederick otto thanks for your time this
evening
let's move on to some of today's other
climate news now winter has arrived in
moscow as snow covers the city now the
last time the russian capital had
snowfall this heavy on 7th of december
was 70 years ago back in 1949
so more than 70 years ago more than 70
000 workers have been clearing snow all
over the city with a wintry weather due
to continue overnight
and this year saw the fifth warmest
november on record globally according to
the eu's cup initials climate change
service
its monthly report found that the most
of the north america
northeastern canada and a large part of
siberia experienced temperatures well
above average
great britain and ireland hit near
record autumn warm
the uk government's been taken to court
for promising to provide more than a
billion dollar funding to a liquefied
natural gas project in mozambique
campaigners friends of the earth say
that it's a climate wrecking gas project
gas mega projects that could emit up to
4.4 billion tons of greenhouse gases
over its lifetime a spokesperson for the
government says it does not comment on
ongoing legal proceedings
the parts of the glasgow climate pact
agreed at the cop 26 climate summit
where historic at least according to the
minister alex sharma that was his
message under questioning from mps in a
common select committee this afternoon
it was his first appearance at the
committee since the summit and he
emphasized how the agreement focused on
the ability to measure how countries
will reach the targets essential for
tackling climate change
well i'm now joined by our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
and hannah this was of course alex
sharma's um first um where hannah there
you are this is of course alex sharma's
first appearance since cop 26 took place
you were watching it what did you make
of it
it was very interesting wasn't it to see
this critical public figure emerging as
the face of climate change uh policy
making not just on the domestic front
but also internationally be questioned
really quite closely by a range of mps
but particularly
by the green party mp caroline lucas and
i guess the pressure on alok sharma who
presided over the glasgow climate pact
and drove that agreement over the line
as loosely falling into two buckets and
that's why he was being questioned at
such length
um at this committee hearing the first
was on the international front and he
was asked over and over again
on this on on the central bit of the
climate pact from the uk's point of view
in the us as well which is is he
confident that individual nations will
actually come back at the end of 2022
with better ambitions with enhanced
ambitions for reducing carbon emissions
if from the uk's point of view that was
the critical element of the glasgow
climate pact is what ratchets up
ambition it's what makes hitting those
net zero targets more and more likely
and alexander admitted that it is a big
ask and he has to do that because you
know the eu
and the us and others have started to
say well it might be a real challenge
alok sharma also pressed on domestic
agenda for the uk so can he
make good on promises to insulate homes
and install heat pumps alongside the uk
government which is of course driving
all of that uh policy side of things
and he admitted that there were some big
challenges ahead he acknowledged that
the climate change committee had told uh
the government that there was some work
to do on its policy agenda but we're
going to see more and more of this from
alex sharma he is increasingly emerging
as the face of the battle against
climate change for the uk government
hannah thank you
now livestock accounts for around 15
percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions much of that from cattle who
emits huge amounts of methane
researchers in ireland are looking into
one solution swapping traditional feed
for seaweed
[Music]
seaweed additives
can reduce methane substantially in
ruminants a red seaweed
has been shown to reduce methane by 80
percent
[Music]
what we are trying to get to by 2030 is
to actually reduce methane by 30
from ruminants
in a climate emergency there is no doubt
about that and it's the most important
thing for us to do in the ruminant
sector
[Music]
please stay with us because coming up
after the break
i'll be joined by environmental
campaigner and member of the house of
lords baroness worthington and simon
lewis who is professor of global change
science at ucl and we'll be discussing
what we can do to adapt to more frequent
extreme weather events and if it's time
to cut back on christmas excess for the
sake of the planet
[Music]
april is the
sixth turtle of the marine savers
flying turtles program
the marine sailors program in the
maldives rescues and rehabilitates
turtles um but unfortunately they can't
provide forever homes so we've flown
april over to a sea life rock moment up
in scotland
where we can replicate
her natural habitat and she will live
out the rest of the life here with us
with our expert animal care team
it's actually taken us three years to uh
come to this stage in the project um
there's various permits
um the authorities you know have
stringent checks as to uh where she's
going to be living long term
and there's also health checks that need
to be taken place and we flew over to
the maldives we have to pack her up and
put vaseline on her and as you can see
on the video there you can see it loaded
onto the british airways flight with the
help of iag cargo
what happened was she was found back in
april 2019 hence her name
she was found entangled in a ghost net
which is um common
in the maldives unfortunately fishermen
throw the nets over the side of the
boats she was found entangled and she
already had a front flipper amputated
and also um as a result of her injuries
she's got lung tests so she's got
buoyancy problems
so as you can see she she can't dive
down so she can't
fend for herself in the wild she can't
feed and and it's very hot in the
maldives obviously with the sun
so because she can't die down under
water um she's not protected from the
elements she's settling in really really
well we've had to do a phased
introduction because obviously it's it's
a completely different environment for
her so it's a big change a big journey
so we've been um having her in
quarantine
part of the time and then we've been
introducing her gradually to a new home
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
stormborough continues to bring some
disruption wednesday morning will be
windy for many with severe coastal gales
still possible in the southwest there'll
be plenty of showers around some heavy
and prolonged with further wintriness on
northern hills it'll feel cold for most
the winds will ease across more of
northern and central britain later but
the showers will keep going into the
evening
looking at the uk's air pollution the
unsettled conditions will keep levels
low measuring just two or three on the
daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news
and we're getting straight to the
discussion that's on climate issues of
the day the environmental campaigner and
member of the house of lords baroness
worthington and also simon lewis
professor of global change science at
ucl we'll be speaking to them now as we
were hearing earlier in the program
storm barrow has been affecting
communities across ireland wells and the
north of england and as global warming
continues to increase the effects of
climate change mean that extreme weather
events are likely to become more
frequent and of course intense in the
future so let me just come to you first
bryony i mean we can't put every storm
to climate change but are we ready
hello um no you're absolutely right um
you know winter storms have been with us
for forever really but what we're going
to be seeing in the future is much more
intense and more frequent storms and we
really need to start getting better at
predicting the severity of those storms
so that we can then um take action to
try and make sure that we have the least
damage and and don't have any losses of
life um we've got to get ready for
what's in a store ahead of us and
arguably we're starting very late in
that process so it's really time we
started to talk about this as a nation
and simon this is a second storm to hit
the uk
in just uh the last few weeks there's
thousands of people still without power
are we prepared to deal with their
upsets we don't seem to have the
infrastructure in place
yes
it seems that that we are not prepared
for
these kind of storms and more generally
we're not very well prepared for
the impacts of climate change
uh what the kind of simple equation is
is that we can either mitigate climate
change reduce emissions adapt to those
impacts or suffer and there seems to be
a lot of suffering coming down the line
because of a lack of reducing emissions
and a lack of adaptation there was a
report by the statute
three
uh advisers to the government the
committee on climate change and and and
they said that we were woefully
inadequately prepared
for climate impacts
and bryony do you think that people are
aware that we're going to be having more
of these storms and crucially are they
ready and prepared to deal with them do
they know how to handle this
i don't think we really are aware and
it's probably no surprise because we
haven't actually had any public
information broadcasting from the
government on climate since really since
the 2000s and it's been sort of left to
people to find out information as best
they can and i think obviously we've
been a bit distracted in the last couple
of years with another crisis but that
shouldn't really take our eye off the
the longer term threat that we need to
get ready for this crisis this is kind
of waiting in the wings it's not going
to go away um the physics of climate
change is is really you can't negotiate
with it so it's it's in store for us um
and as you know we really need to um see
the government take a lead in helping
people understand those simple things
like just thinking about your home and
understanding how vulnerable you might
be either to extreme heat in the summer
or exposure to flooding or even just
high winds people
start to think about their homes as not
being perhaps as safe as they once were
and starting to prepare for it um we
don't want to alarm anyone but we also
don't want to have people just you know
going into this with ignorance and we
can prepare and that will help to stop
people from feeling the damaging effects
well simon just going on what brian he
just said then is our government too
reactive do we only think about flood
defenses after we've had floods
and it seems to be
the case uh that we
uh see
an impact and and only then start to
think about it and
scientists have given an
ample warning of the kind of impacts of
climate change the heat waves the heavy
rainfall events
and we should really be moving fast to
have a public information campaign as
brian he says to help the public
understand the issues and what they can
do about them but crucially we have this
10-point plan from the government about
how to reduce emission how it's going to
reduce emissions but we don't have an
equivalent 10-point plan about how we're
going to adapt to climate change and
what the government is going to invest
to make sure that our critical national
infrastructure and our homes are
resilient for what's coming in the 21st
century okay well let's just move on to
our next topic there and there is a
warning today that the price of
traditional christmas lunch ingredients
is rising with the cost of frozen turkey
up seven percent for example in
christmas puddings five percent more
expensive than last year well the
festive season is typically a time of
excess we're all guilty of that we but
with a third of all food produced around
the world being wasted each year and the
cost of produce going up is it time to
cut back and how much we buy well let me
throw that one to you there um simon do
we need to start rethinking our approach
to the festive season
well it's a no-brainer that we shouldn't
buy food and then throw it away because
it's it's a waste of money and also it
does does have carbon uh climate change
implications but it's also a question
about what we buy and therefore what we
waste for christmas dinner uh
a kill of
beef
wood about 60 kilograms
of carbon dioxide equivalent whereas a
turkey would be around six or seven
kilograms kilograms of co2 for a kilo of
turkey where the nut roast
would be about less than one kilo so
what what we buy matters as well as what
we waste but perhaps uh those people who
have excess money that they can buy food
and throw it away should probably buy a
bit less maybe
in the spirit of christmas donate that
much
let's bring in bryony because um simon
sound then bryony look consumers are
already paying for more food prices
going up energy prices going up is it
fair to put the responsibility of
climate on our mills you know especially
around christmas time
uh i i think the
there needs to be a big conversation
about how we produce food and
what that impact of that is on on the
planet it's been a you know success
story in many ways that we've kept food
prices low we've seen productivity of of
land grow but it's come at a price and
that price has been you know loss of
nature but also we've contributed hugely
to greenhouse gas emissions from the
land use sector so there is a definite
need for a new conversation um we've had
a bit of a tough couple of years and i
don't think anyone wants to be a killjoy
in relation to the first season um but
being a bit more thoughtful about it
thank you thank you very much indeed
brian simon thank you very much indeed
for your time this evening well do stay
tuned because coming up next on sky news
tonight there are fears that christmas
could be cancelled after the uk records
its highest number of weekly covert
cases since january we'll have more
coming up next thank you very much
indeed for watching do you have a lovely
evening whatever you're up to bye for
now